john-paul are constantly going back and
forth in fact it was a dizzying degree
and they would let's say borrow things
from some of the hospitals to improve
the situation in Haiti
actually the first sake we had at the
lab was bought by Paul from combustible
that was a clip from bending the arc
it's a new documentary that chronicles
the journey of some idealistic young
doctors who helped change the way public
health issues are addressed especially
in developing nations to the benefit of
millions and for this week's morning
rounds CBS News chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook sat down
with two of the film's key figures in
the documentary how long do you guys
know each other
December 1983 34 years 34 years would
you ever have imagined that you'd be
where you are now I definitely would
have imagined Jim as president obey dr.
Jim Yong Kim and dr. Paul Farmer
attended medical school together at
Harvard in the 1980s it's there in
Boston where the foundation for their
life's work would take shape you have to
continue to ask okay now what's the most
important thing I can do to really lift
people out of poverty to provide
healthcare education provide them jobs
and it's sustained us and it's sustained
the groove alongside like-minded people
such as dr. o philia Dahl the nonprofit
Health Organization Partners in Health
was born their story is told in a new
documentary bending the arc there was an
arc from just the few of you meeting so
many years ago to where you are now what
is bending the arc mean so it's a it's a
saying I mean Martin Luther King used to
talk about it at the arc of history is
long but it bends toward justice but for
us I think the lesson has been that if
you look at Martin Luther King's life
the arc of history doesn't bend toward
justice unless people grab the arc and
bend it toward justice a common theme
throughout the movie and their lives has
been fighting conventional wisdoms there
was one especially poignant moment in
the film there was a young man who was
on death's door he had drug-resistant
tuberculosis tell me about that so I had
first two scene Melquiades in 2006 and I
was there for a short visit and I
participated in his care I participated
in trying to get him to stay on his
therapy and frankly in 2006 when I left
I didn't think he was gonna make it
Melquiades Hawaii did indeed
get at one point in the film dr. Kim is
shown video of what his old patient from
Peru looks like now when you see
something like that it's amazing to see
the recovery but is it also sort of like
that fury yeah my reaction first was it
was to weep but then my second reaction
was really admonishing ourselves because
we almost let him go and so the thought
that I had right at that moment is can
you believe we almost were too late can
you believe we almost left out
Melquiades and and it was sort of I
believe you added because it was
inconvenient and and we so much of that
happens I mean when it comes to the
lives of the poor so much of the worst
things that happened to them happened
because good people embraced the
conventional wisdom and turned their
heads away dr. farmer has done anything
but look away I saw that firsthand five
years ago walking the halls of a new
teaching hospital Partners in Health
helped build in Haiti I remember an
exact quote from you you said it's about
time as you saw yourself after the
earthquake conventional wisdom was that
this was not a ranking priority to build
an academic Medical Center after such
devastation but if it's not a ranking
priority then when would it when would
it be making it a priority paid off just
a few years after the hospital opened
conjoined twins were successfully
separated a first in Haiti thinking
globally has been part of their approach
from the start five years ago dr. Kim
became president of the World Bank I
think the work that Paul continues to do
in building these health systems
building schools building houses this is
the right thing that's doing everybody
investing in people in the poorest
countries is in fact a critically
important thing to do for the global
economy but certainly for the world that
our children and grandchildren will live
in a lot has been accomplished in the 34
years since they met but both are aware
of the heavy lifting that remains is
piling up of innovate
for some people and privation for others
and you know that's a I would say that's
the biggest problem we have facing
medicine is these disparities that
affect every field as we look back on
the Civil Rights era as we look back on
the era in which we weren't going to
treat the 25 million people living with
HIV in Africa young people today so can
you believe we thought that I think the
task for every young person today is to
ask themselves what are the things that
we're doing or not doing today that in
20 years will look back and say can you
believe that's the way we thought
Partners in Health does amazing amazing
work these two men are so impressive so
impressive documentary is bending the
arc